hallo meine damen und herren mein name
ist luca wir haben eine grüne ampel
ich befinde mich gerade mit max wir
fahren gerade zum rewe bei denen ich vor
einigen tagen auch das event hatte wohl
ich pizza verteilt habe ich musste bei
dem event auf jeden fall am ende relativ
schnell denkmal noch sehr viele leute da
waren und dass dann alles ein bisschen
eskaliert deswegen habe ich die pizzen
vergessen dich eigentlich mitnehmen
sollte aber deswegen fahren wir hin und
ich würde sagen wir sind es beim rewe
wieder wenn wird da reingehen
[Musik]
ich dachte der bitkom nova kam nicht ja
meine damen und herren wir waren jetzt
hier gerade im rewe haben noch die
pizzen bekommen noch ein paar zuschauer
von leuchter getroffen war auch neues
heim mein name ist mika dustin like
david auf jeden fall die finger bekommen
waren jetzt zu mir nach hause und dort
meine damen und herren ich habe schon
den titel gelesen machen wir ein
wettessen stopp stopp stopp das
a
junge reporterin jetzt hier die große
auch man jetzt noch mal auf zu viel wie
immer youtuber alltäglichen auf betriebs
arten und zwar auf ich habe habe ich um
luft und lüften heißluft es
wahrscheinlich ist das okay gut ich hab
ich einfach voran annehmen weil ich bin
auch so heißt dann wird er auch als ich
freu mich extra weg damit unique hab
einfach steine in meinem kühlschrank was
lohn und jetzt fange ich mir die luca
pizza dabei und jetzt müsste es
eigentlich passen genau also jetzt
kinder die auch hast doch gesagt obwohl
du gesagt hast dass wir sie nicht
eingestimmt das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr diese diese sticker
ist in jeder hundertste pizza donnerstag
das war das mit zucker gerade wir gucken
jetzt mal eine andere rein und haben
auch sonst interessiert ist hier ist ein
ganz normaler sticker darin die liebe zu
ihr ist auch schon ein bisschen auch wir
gucken wir mal rein
auch ein ganz normaler sticker drin
alter unterschrift von comcom schafft
berlins youtuber nicht mal zurück was
meine damen und herren die pizza jetzt
hier reingelegt nach vorne liegt sie
drin und wir haben das den vorlauf 8
minuten eingestellt weil wir das in ober
unterhitze gemacht haben ich hab den
fokus nicht richtig und man braucht ja
meine damen und herren
und jetzt freuen da haben wir nämlich
den karton dann können wir hier hinten
befestigen
jetzt können wir hier einfach die pizza
einladen das heißt ich würde sagen wir
nehmen jetzt erstmal eine eine gabel
fixen wir die pizza rein theoretisch
schon gut mit dabei
gut schneiden wir die jetzt im fall
helga kann ihr seht meine damen und
herren hier ist nichts passiert wirklich
den karton also ihr könnt das ganze dann
schneiden beim wirklich wenn man es
nicht normalen tellern ich das amt
einfach über heldts voll wasser
du bist du was meint ihr seid überlappen
leute werden für die zweite fans haben
kann ich euch gerne schauen mitteilen
dass der bessere kanal auf youtube
contractor essig als ihre pendants dinge
die etwas trinken so damals für glück
immer wenn man sie deine halten peter
jetzt hier auf den teller getan und
quasi halbiert er wir müssen jetzt
unsere hände hinter dem rücken packen
und jetzt waren wir quasi pizza in essen
mit meiner
ohne hände die haben uns ja die ganze
zeit sachen überlege der fahrlehrer
machen muss aber warum war deswegen ist
der verlierer ein fucking verlierer ist
bereit 19 ist bereit ist das bereits 321
[Musik]
und was macht man sich das ist lecker
war
nur über tag und verloren damit mein
herze springen jetzt schon mal zweiter
[Musik]
ich denk mir kamera arbeitet als ich
bitte es
[Musik]
ich gucke nicht mehr
wohin gehst du dabei ua du bist der
sieger mein glückwunsch auch weniger
tomaten presse selbst geworden haben ich
meine positiven das kann ich erst mal
das gewicht von crafter sollte man auf
jeden fall ausstieg auf dem kanal letzte
video aufgenommen ja freunde das was sie
mit dem challenge ich habe leider
grandios verloren die pizzas aber
trotzdem lecker wir machen jetzt noch
eine zweite pizza wird max kanal
tatsächlich auch noch ein video auf dem
werden wo wir pizza essen mit stäbchen
machen werden und ob ich da punkten kann
seht ihr noch max kann als sonst würde
ich jetzt sagen meine nummer eins in
deutschland europa und weltweit ist die
pizza suche wir werden euch die zürcher
gefallen haben die wende denkmal
challenges mit lukas pizza ab leicht
1000 quadratmeter für das pizza oder
meine pizza klicken sie bitte auf luca
pizza lassmann leiter und schreib mal
luca pizza und die kommentare und jetzt
kommt das auto hob das ziel von bio das
war es jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
schenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]